we look like twins right now bro oh yeah
dude we do we got the black the two hats
uh everyone that's Nick xano with me who
is Chad mcnight in obliterate which is
out now on Netflix we're going to talk
spoilers so make sure you watch the show
first before we jump into this Nick how
you doing today man I'm doing great man
What's happen you watch the show yeah I
loved it I binged it this weekend and
I'm telling everyone to watch it and how
just awesome it is and really funny too
and what really blew my mind in just
preparing for this interview was that
saw your IMDb bio says you long dreamed
of becoming a Navy SEAL was this the way
you had imagined it coming to be first
of all when I was a child I saw uh
Charlie Sheen's Navy Seals o uh that one
and it was on
HBO I could have
swore I was going to be uh a Navy SEAL
when I was a child like that was the
only thing I was like that's all I want
to be this all I want me and um and
here's here's an interesting true story
I went to look I've never told this
story before into enlisting into the
military I went to a recruiter's office
I went home I didn't pick up the phone
my mother picked up the phone and the
recruiter starts talking to my mother
about me coming in and my mother said
leave my son alone he's not going
anywhere and up on the recruiter and I
came home and she was like what are you
doing thinking you're
joining you joining the military and I
was like Mom I was like you're
embarrassing me in front of the US
military that's amazing and then yeah
and then through you know in uh through
a course of you know the Journey of life
and everything that
happens you know decades later you're
like I actually get to do it I get to
play play
pretended but I get to be advised by the
real deal like Kevin Kent our military
advisor certified badass got to spend
time with him and have him teach me some
tricks of the trade and some lingo and
small talk and you know physical
movements uh yeah wild right man you're
the first one to catch that no and I I
think uh you do a great job as an abcl I
was completely sold and it's also
interesting that's not the only cool
thing that's part about Chad's character
what I love too is this like love
triangle he's in but I feel like he's
not aware of part of that do you sense
that he sensed at some point Maya's
obsession with him can you kind of clear
that
up I feel mcnight exists in this space
where like to him it's like Oh I like
that I'm gonna have that like I like
this I'm GNA have this and if he's
focused on what he likes
he may be oblivious
to emotionally the other things anything
else in life like anybody walk in people
emotionally he could miss a lot of [__]
but alert wise in the game wise I don't
think he's missing much on the Tactical
end but possibly on the emotional end
okay yeah that that's a fair answer and
I think that's what makes him endearing
in the end and I have to talk about that
scene in episode five when uh Chad saves
trunk um that was one of the most
difficult things for me to watch Ever uh
was that as hard to be a part of a scene
as it is for us the audience watching
that um I had it was a very extremely
close set that day not a little bit
close set but like a very heavily
guarded close set right and I had to
walk in at this point Terren and I are
very good friends and I care about
Terren and who plays
trunk um I walk into set it's dead
quiet parents is tied up and this is a
spoiler yes spoilers all spoilers you
can go yeah parents is tied up his pants
are on his ankles and the thing is
inside of them oh God and I walk in and
see it and it created an effect from my
belly button to my throat it's just like
just this feeling of like F like what
and then I look at Terrence and he's
like I know I know and I'm like oh buddy
then we're we're setting up camera and
it's right there it's right there and
I'm standing there and I look at Terence
I'm just like shaking my head of like
you know it's just one of those moments
when you're doing stuff like this you're
like what is this life right what is
life what are we doing like how did this
happen where did I go right and where
did I go wrong like like how do we end
up here and it just you do that in like
a head nod and a shoulder shrug and
Terren put the prosthetic in my hand
okay and I'm like who he's like you
gotta do it you're doing it in the scene
we got to just break the ice with it and
I'm like okay breaking the ice breaking
the ice and I'm like all right I slapped
him my both shoulders I'm like ice is
broken got
it wow and then we did it and um it's
it's something man it is something we
won't forget that no that that's a scene
that just stays in your brain forever
and it was intense so yeah I mean when
you guys were talking up the show too
how intense it was be and you were
saying online like you know be careful
with this like I you didn't undersell it
so that that was what was nuts about it
and um honestly wa there's just one
thing like people you hear that and you
think like I'm trying to like give you
make you think some a certain way this
is actually that way as you saw it like
I mean what I say to you do not watch
this with your family I mean when I say
to you don't watch this with your mom
like I mean it like once you see it
you're gonna be like oh thank God I
watched this not at
work yeah exactly and um thing I'm just
wondering too if if the show gets a SE
two could we see more of Chad's
backstory explored because he does
mention that his dad had left him at a
young age do you see that as a
possibility I would love that one of my
favorite scenes is with Victoria Matson
uh three I
believe where we're at mcnight at home
with his
mom uh that was a sweet interesting
piece and you know um I want the guy to
be from Florida he's he's a Florida guy
in the scene I wore a very famous
Florida only thing that you will get and
it's a Muk Bowl shirt and that mckb
shirt is like straight up for Florida
people only and they get it and I would
love to explore mcnight at home in
Florida like more than anything it's uh
I I would love to it would make my heart
so happy yeah that's there's a there's a
parallel to um to like I've never met my
father I've only been raised by like the
women in my family my mother my
grandmother my great-grandmother my my
aunt uh and my dad's alive and well I've
never met him I don't know him uh so
when that was in the script that changes
the dynamic between mother and
son so when it was time for mcnight and
his mom to be together I I know that
difference between a mother and a son
and no father vers a mother father son
because then there's just like it's a
different thing but that scene is just a
taste of it's just the two of them it's
just the two of them vers the world and
uh that's what anchors that and like
some heaviness for me and the character
as well yeah and and why I would just
kill for season two and to see that
story more explored that's really
powerful stuff that's awesome to hear
that and uh I also have to ask you when
the opportunity comes for you to play
Brad Pit in the biopic of his life will
you answer the
call first of all um I
wish I wish uh second my face has become
a roar Shack test to some people
like and it happens in front of me we
like no it's this no it's that and but
it's me as a person um and I witness I'm
the man I don't I don't see it because
it's me I don't see anything because
it's me um I wish it was the way you
said it was uh but I will say uh I I
have one story where I was on a flight
um I was on a flight to
Paris and I was with a few friends and
we were sitting down and the steward and
the captain were talking while we were
sitting down and uh we're kind of
minding our own business and as the
flight was coming to an end the stst
came over and handed me the flight
Manifesto the print out and my name was
xed out and she had B pit on
it and I looked at her and I go no and
then she goes
it's okay like that and it walked away
and I was like No And and I looked at my
friends on and everyone was like we saw
that and I have a picture of the
manifesto it was like so it was so crazy
and farfetched I was like I took a
picture of it like circulated amongst
the friends on that but uh I don't see
it I I wish it to be true
please Lord Almighty Let It Be True no I
love it and this is probably the closest
I'll get to uh ever interviewing Brad
Pit so thank you for that uh everybody
watch Nick kill it in obliterated over
and over tell your friends about it keep
watching again let's get the word out
and get people watching it's so funny
and so much fun in general thank you so
much Nick for joining me today I hope
talk to you in the future bye man thank
you wonderful questions